hallo wir machen heute eine britisch
kein lied challenge.de kraft und lecker
wir haben hier ganz viele sachen haben
starte ich mir gleich alle essen werden
wir haben unterstellt diese süßigkeiten
und getränke und alles sieht relativ süß
und zum krieg aus kellogg square ja wir
haben wir wachen kommen die wir
tatsächlich irgendwie in deutschland
wählen damit sind wir ziemlich kennen
und mir doch kein plate mit für
irgendwas aus der hand deswegen werden
alle produkte helfen das richtige nach
vanille bisschen war schnell und günstig
dass klebrig ist wichtig was in der
nämlichen schnauze rhein bei ntt klar
aber das ist so wie ich zu verwackeln
sobald man das volk wieder munter bildet
das nach nur noch ein kleines bisschen
passt ich fragte was passiert mit
solchen sachen den technikern deswegen
gerade in einem hostel und er gibt eine
gemeinschaftsküche und da werden wir
also rein stellen nicht dafür dass
wegschmeißen oder zahlen uns gedacht
indem man getränk uns war
ich habe die bena mango die metal ist
hier was er schlug sie aber leider nicht
manchmal gar nicht die geilheit wir
haben nur sachen die du bist kraftwerken
toppen
ja dann schmeckt die dr pepper mit nein
kann ich nicht so wichtig süßen also
konnte hier noch haben wir auf jeden
fall beide diabetes schaut euch das an
davis
das ist einfach nur zucker hat nicht als
noch einmal noch einmal
heute sucht man sich einen zehntel
auseinander
so oder so übertrieben
die zähne kleben wirklich daran dass
zunächst das haben wir hier
wer also irgendwie wissen wir nicht ob
da gleich irgendwas rauskommen bedeuten
- aufgedreht hat hätte sie da drin
irgendwie so ein schwarzes nur traum
wahr das ist für mich so trauben ist so
verbraucher ja ich weiß gar nicht wie
kann man das beschreiben was müssen wir
wirklich gesundes essen also das können
wir eigentlich einfach nach unten hin
stellen vereinfachen so ich mag frauen
sogar das nächste was wir haben sind so
minimiert ich weiß nicht ob das das
steht mir aber ging auch crazy german
hintergrund alles lag ich noch mal
kaputt geht mit 15 0
ich geb dir einfach mal einig nehmen und
den letzten winter
sie sind wie dieser gruppe dran diese
zahl wächst
[Musik]
da muss man das matching perfekt also
freunde schreibt in die kommentare a und
b und c oder ce fox hat thiering das
sind irgendwie so donath artige teile
alter das sind genau solche diese
downloads aus den zinsen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
doch nicht einfach gesagt ja ich weiß
nicht was man hier in england für partys
haben wir männer die kochen chupa chups
das ist so ein kleiner
die glücklichen liebe übernehmen oder
auch jetzt will jetzt mit 1000 kommt
sogar haye würde ich noch mehren kamera
kann ihn nicht mal tauschen wir ich habe
liberia da haben wir die war das getränk
von luca davor allerdings bringt jetzt
kurse also ich hab auch zu diesen cassis
geschmack wo ist das geil als auch durch
probier mal ich hab mal richtig glück
schmeckt die fanta
[Musik]
das probiere ich jetzt mal freunde und
irgendwas mit flüssigkeit drin und auch
eine spritze
du bekommst von mir ein paar welche
davon die hälfte zu machen ich werde
niemals vereinbart die chancen auf einen
schlag hat schlimme war zwischen den
zehen leicht hatte ich schon sagt ist
ein paradies gesehen im extra ding
aufgebaut
es bringt überhaupt nicht an lee so das
nächste was wir haben
wenn ich ganz lecker uns balance crunchy
nut das ist einfach so ein frühstück
nicht zu aber so ein frühstück du bist
wirklich einfach früchte großen
unterschied ohne milch ist ob das nicht
schon hast du [ __ ] alter das ist mein
einziger aus der suite an ich habe drauf
wir werden jetzt wohl vorbei ich beide
in großer angst haben ist der kipling
zuckerschock diabetes die zweite junge
mann
[Musik]
wir haben die leute ist einen sind schon
cupcakes es nicht auch einmal zu haben
[Musik]
ich hasse amarena kirsch besser fertig
denke das ist nicht so schlimm sagt aber
max meint richtig schwimmen
ich kenne das dass deutschland nicht
genutzt echten fans aus deutschland
selbst noch nie war schon gesehen das
ist von test komplett schmecken die gute
essen and its troop
[Musik]
sie macht ja schon schlampig die kenne
ich das natürlich dass diese chips nach
becken schmecken gut verstehen dass
minister stimmt so nicht haben ich
aussehe freunde haben werden jetzt essen
wir gem
rogers für nicht mehr alle die packen
zusammen wird klar spielt auch das sind
so doppelseitige wie so spitz kommende
weihnachtszeit junge arbeit nicht mag es
keinen ganzen
[Musik]
michael top-liga ich dachte jetzt das
ende aussuchen und zwar haben wir nur
noch die dicken backen
man wird noch dreckiger zu machen
bisschen zeit nicht mehr offen
das sind keine normalen keks die sind so
wurde jetzt kein ganz nicht was mir mal
ich glaube ich brauche man zunehmend
keinen zucker mehr freunde das war's
jetzt mit dieser ich habe ich
bauchschmerzen
so sieht das sehr gut aus ich hab mir
das so kraft aber hier liegt hier sind
überall da diese ganzen sachen werden
wir jetzt noch ins hostel küche dings
tun das siegerfohlen bereite ich noch
dass unsere getränke freuen ist er viel
zu krass die schicksale so unerschrocken
niemand
ich hab mir überlegt was mich aber ich
hab mit herzlichen glückwunsch gut ist
oder schlecht freundin
wenn es euch gefallen nach können sie
dem video wird
die fans feiern könnt ihr dann wieder
auf jeden fall ein nein da muss mir
helfen